what our domain and range really simple
idea right we've got a function right
any function and by the way we've learnt
function notation before
how will we write in a nice concise way
like name a function say F right how
would we write it f just FX like that
I'm sorry I hear some language and I
hear some symbols right I think I heard
f of X and to indicate that of
yeah we've been racketeering there okay
well parentheses if you want to be
really fancy now what we mean here is f
is the name of a function we're going to
put in values called X into it and then
something else will come out right so we
know how functions work you're familiar
with functions just different language
on a new idea domain and range are
simply where can this function go where
is this function allowed to exist right
okay so how are we gonna work this out
right f of X its domain right is its and
this is you have a little table there
right so it's domain of range it's
coordinates domain are about the x
coordinates right so these are the which
which set of axes is these is this the
up and down one or the crossbones is the
horizontal one right this is horizontal
okay so when you have a function its
domain is the X values the horizontal
values that it's allowed to take on I'm
gonna give an example this in a second
right but these are the things you can
put into your heading right the
coordinates of the x coordinates the
axis is the horizontal axis and what we
call it right there values where the
function exists so this is your third
row on your table right we call that
domain okay now we have a corresponding
thing for y values for vertical values
and that's what we mean by range okay so
it's range
this is interested in where can I go up
and down on the Cartesian plane right so
therefore it's about the vertical values
okay now let's just think about some
very simple functions that we already
know about in fact if you have a look at
the bottom of that page I'm gonna start
with one that we've been dealing with a
fair bit quadratics we're very familiar
with is I don't think it's the first one
its Part B okay
so if we just have a look Part B I know
you might be wondering why is it
question seven I'll explain that later
papí it says y equals x squared plus
five okay now the easiest way to work
out where are the domain and range going
to be is just draw a picture it doesn't
have to be beautiful but the picture
will help us answer this question easily
okay so underneath way you're writing
the function just draw a really small
set of axes for me it doesn't have to be
beautiful just enough so we can actually
put some stuff on it here's my set of
axes now what kind of shape will X
square plus five be it has a name
it starts with the P it's a parabola
right so we know is gonna be a parabola
here is it gonna be facing down is it
you may facing up up okay how could you
tell by the way there's a positive value
at the front of x squared right the
coefficient is positive so it's going to
be going up like this can you tell me
anything else about this graph from the
numbers that are on there yeah we're
gonna take a regular old parabola and
we're going to raise it up five units
okay with that so go ahead and draw on
your axes something like this that's a
bit off you get the idea use your
imagination okay now I'm not gonna
stress you guys out about the graph too
much because the graph is not the point
the graph is just an instrument okay how
can we use this to work out the domain
and the range well where can this graph
where can this function go horizontally
are there any places it's not allowed to
go so I'm thinking about what values of
X remember when you like substituted
things in to here I'm asking what values
of X are you allowed to put into this
and get a reasonable answer at the other
end can you put in values like zero
really F of zero if I put 0 into where X
is do we not get a reasonable value at
the other end I'll get I'll get a result
right I'll get 0 squared plus 5 which
the last time I checked was 0 plus 5
which is 5 thank you ok I get it's late
in the afternoon
come on brain so we can do it so zero is
fine how about like 10 can I put 10 in
here yeah you get 10 squared 105
my graph doesn't look that big but could
I put like a million in there sure why
not
I'm not going to draw that obviously but
there's nothing stopping me how about
negative values come with your negative
values they're fine can you think of it
I'm going to pose the same question to
you go can you think of any values that
you can't put into this function yes can
we put decimals in this try 1 1.1 1.1
squared it's like 11 that's 1.2 1 plus
Phi it's fine
right and that's why this graph doesn't
have any holes in it it's not like yeah
so I can put anything I like in here in
terms of X which means the way I would
say this is the domain and love you to
write this with me the domain of this
particular function is and you can say
this in lots of ways but the way I'm
gonna encourage you to say is all real
values of X okay and there's some fancy
ways to write this especially if you
don't want to use all these long words
this is gonna look weird but it's much
more succinct and I promise you'll get
to like it you can write your X right
and then draw this Greek letter Epsilon
it's like an e but it's curvy okay and
to indicate real values we use just look
up for a second and watch the way I do
this because it's not that hard but you
want to watch me do it
you can do kind this fat looking R with
two lines that are vertical and then you
then you do the rest of the R did you
see how I did that should go bang bang
and then do the rest of the letter
that's how we indicate real values the
set of real numbers okay so yeah this
means for now I'm just going to give you
a sort of informal definition which
basically means X can be any of the real
values it has a more technical debt
formal definition than that but we don't
have to worry about it for now
this domain for x-values
you can't put in any x value that you'd
like right for instance let me try one
if f of X were this function whoops
square root if I put in 0 f of 0 right
everywhere I see an X I will replace it
with a 0 is that ok so I get this yeah 2
times 0 which of course is 0 0 take away
5 so I'm getting this and your
calculator doesn't like this does it
right this is math error because I'm
like don't take the square roots of
negative numbers that's what it's
telling you to do right ok ok so we know
that we can't do 0 which is no surprise
here it is see how it's not on the graph
there's no spot on the graph there so I
probably can't do these values either
like they're probably a bad idea you see
how they intersect with the graph so
whatever whatever that spot is now
what's that spot it's 2 and a half right
are you allowed to put exactly two and a
half in there well the great things here
is you could just check right like to
take the value put it in 2 times 2 and
1/2 is 5 the square root of 5 minus 5 is
it can you take the squares here a
square root is the number that you
multiply by itself that gives you that
number right what's the number that you
multiply by itself that gives you 0 0 so
that's totally fine right so here's what
I'm gonna say the domain it's going to
be about the X values right I'm gonna go
from 2 and 1/2 to the right anything
bigger than 2 and 1/2 like 3 or 4 or 5
or 8 million right not to scale anything
to that direction is fine so I'm gonna
say greater than or equal to what would
you say to 1/2 right now then ok
can you look at the graph and now tell
me about the Y values where is the graph
go where doesn't it go
yes so the graph doesn't go below zero
yeah and remember I'm thinking up down
now okay so here's zero and up here is
one two three four five down here is
negative set again has a really good
question can we shorten these two rather
than domain and range can we just write
D and ah I would highly encourage you
not to here's why more so with this guy
here when you've got things that can
mean other things in maths right you
don't want to make things ambiguous and
so I'd prefer you to state something and
say I know exactly what that is there's
complete clarity that I know what you're
talking about as opposed to D for
distance or D for displacement or any of
the other things that it could stand for
okay so it's six letters by the time we
finish arguing about you or your feet
writing it yeah okay all right so the
range our y-values right it's gonna be
yeah I'm gonna look at zero and I'm
allowed to go above but not below okay
can we be equal to we tried this out
right we tried this out if we put
exactly x equals two and a half in we
get exactly y equals zero out so it's um
it's included it's included okay